I want to talk about why I consume four
eggs every single day I did a seminar at
Exxon many years ago and I noticed they
didn't invite me back and I called him
up I said why can't I come back and do
another seminar because I do a seminar
series and they said well you're
recommending 45 eggs a day
I said no no no no I didn't say 45 eggs
a day I said four to five eggs a day
okay
and they go oh okay yeah you can come
back but generally I will need four eggs
and sometimes only need five eggs per
day now of course those eggs are not
consumed at breakfast they're actually
at my first meal right around one or
even two sometimes three o'clock in the
afternoon so one of the key reasons that
I consume eggs on a regular basis not
only do I enjoy it but eggs have the
greatest anabolic effect okay anabolic
means that it's turning into muscle
protein or other proteins so it's
building more protein in the body I have
a little scale here that shows these
percentages and the type of protein so
egg forty eight percent of it actually
turns into body tissue and I'm not
talking about even absorption I'm
talking about forty percent of that egg
actually turns into your body tissue and
that's pretty much the highest not
counting breast milk unless you're a
baby you're not gonna be able to get it
now when we take meat fish file that's
32 percent okay much less an egg white
is 17 percent which is fascinating
because that cholesterol and fat
actually help in the anabolic effect
look at soy only 17 percent it might be
high in amino acids but it does not turn
into body tissue that well dairy whey
this would be like cheese and whey
16 percent very small spirulina six
percent so if we take 4 eggs comes out
to 24 grams of protein times point four
eight so eleven point five two grams are
actually turning in the body
you look at me 24 grams only 7.68 grams
of it is actually turning in the body
tissue so you're gonna have to consume
more meat to get the same efficiency as
for eggs okay
Dairy is only three point four eight
grams actually turning into body tissue
so you can see that you would have to
consume a lot more dairy to create this
effect so eggs are very efficient in
turning in the body tissue not only that
they're very high in nutrients they
pretty much have every single vitamin
and mineral except item and see the load
with B vitamins choline healthy fats
which is right here so it has DHA EPA it
has a lot of the carotenoids which is
good for the eye prevent macular
degeneration
it has choline which helps prevent a
fatty liver and helps your nervous
system now if there's any consideration
your mind that eating eggs will increase
your cholesterol realize that there is
absolutely no data that will increase
your so-called bad cholesterol LDL it
will increase your good cholesterol HDL
so it is not bad for the heart so you
don't have to worry about that so anyway
I just wanted to point this out and
recommend that you also get
pasture-raised organic eggs it's a
little bit more expensive but it's
definitely worth it thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos